vous êtes là excusez moi mais
aujourd'hui je n'aurai pas le temps de
bavarder avec vous j'ai emprunté ce
livre à la bibliothèque il y a trois
mois et je dois le rendre aujourd'hui et
je veux absolument terminer alors je je
suis venu ici pour lire au calme
évidemment j'aurais pu rester chez moi
mais il ya ce bavard de léonard
je parle je parlais et ma lecture
n'avance pas alors excusez-moi mais
soyez gentils eloignez-vous un peu un
bon jour
pour écouter excusez moi mais pas
aujourd'hui je voudrais finir ce livre
absolument une autre fois bon je vais
aller lire derrière le client ce qui ce
serait plus tranquille
les enfants venaient le fabricant de
bonbons mois envoyé des échantillons de
nouveaux bonbons vous savez ce que c'est
qu'un échantillon non non et bien c'est
une petite quantité d'un produit qui
permet d'en apprécier les qualités alors
par exemple c'est bon goût je voulais
donner à goûter vous me direz six boules
et s'ils sont bons on en fera de
nouvelles commandes
d'accord vous voulez goûter il faut
aussi l'avis de casimir où est il
j'aperçois là-bas venez avec moi
casimir est ce que tu pourrais donner
ton avis sur ces bonbons ans julie je ne
peux pas ah bon très bien des jeunes
commandé beaucoup merci mais enfin je
n'ai pas dit oui j'ai dit non oui mais
comme ton avis est toujours opposé à
celui des enfants oh ce n'est pas un
j'adore les dragées au poivre et les
caramels ammouta ou un et alors été un
mauvais caractère qui plus est tien est
ce que tu vas me donner ton avis sur ce
beau monde à la fougère et surtout lui
là où jackman et 6e 3e
merci réponse ne sont très précieux
mais vous avez vu elle a failli
m'étouffer et avec tout ça j'ai raté la
moitié d'un chapitre
allons bon voilà françois maintenant
qu'elle s'est mis à l'essai mais reçoit
gentil et doit apporter ma caisse sur le
banc là bas dépêche toi je vais tout
lâcher ça ne sert à rien de discuter ça
ira plus vite de l'aider
alors
moi je t'ai rencontré puisque sous
vêtements voilà merci c'est gentil mais
non non non non attends attends tu
entends casimir donc quoi elle sera
mieux sur ma chaise si tu vends ma vie
tu
sais pas trop lourde ça va ça va voilà
merci non non casimir la chaise a plié
c'est trop lourd on va la porter plutôt
là bas dans le fond du jardin
il n'y a qu'une solution la fuite
vraiment il y a des jours j'aimerais
être complètement inconnu pour que
personne ne m'adresse la parole
ou hochart léonard qui je franchir le
seuil d'un humble mais reposante maisons
de bois blancs peinte en bleue dans
laquelle casimir à la générosité bonté
d'âme de réserver un coin hors de la
portée des moustiques rieurs et peter
mais bien sûr entraîne monsieur du ce
nom
vous n'êtes pas trop essoufflé d'avoir
dit d'une seule traite et non sinon
france mais pas du tout mon cher léonard
c'est une question de
respiration je respire un dixième de
seconde au virgule un quart de seconde
au point est carrément une demi seconde
au point d'al ahly
vous devez avoir les poumons
particulièrement développés ci pense
monsieur du sandwich une faveur à vous
demande base est accordée d'avant
vous êtes un grand qu'un chantier vous
ne m'avez pas encore raconter vos
vacances et bien mais va qu
attendez vous nous avez raconté à
casimir non plus je vais te les fournir
casimir il est temps jarque
allons jolis plans un citoyen casimir à
ça tombe bien c'est à toi que je voulais
parler il faut que tu viens de vite
monsieur disent non pas nous raconter
ses vacances
il est occupé il ne veut pas perdre de
temps en venant jusqu'ici
à nous casimir bon monsieur les écoutera
par téléphone n'insiste pas où je me
vexe bon et bien figure toi que pendant
les vacances
je ne suis pas passée inaperçue enfin
les enfants ne reconnaissais et me
demandent des autographes alors
résultats j'arrivais toujours deux
heures en retard à mes rendez vous vous
n'exagérez pas un petit peu monsieur dix
membres mais pas du tout
vous auriez dû vous y rendre avec des
lunettes noires
rasant les murs venez dans un journal
vous seriez passée inaperçue oui
incognito non je disais incognito
qu'elle dit mir ça signifie pour des
personnes célèbres changer son aspect
afin de ne pas être reconnu et dit que
c'est une bonne idée
évidemment puisque s'y est une idée de
moi un
haka il a raccroché alors léonard mais
son chapeau françois sa valise et nous
nous excusons quasi nul mais je suis en
train de raconter une histoire aux
enfants ça va arriver à remercier leçons
de morale mais c'est important c'est
important mais je t'écoute casimir asie
comment faut qu'il fera pour garder
l'incognito
karaté incognito c'est un mot compliqué
ça vous savez ce que ça veut dire les
enfants
ne pas se faire montrer c'est ça oui
c'est quelqu'un de très connu qui veut
par exemple pouvoir se promener
tranquillement dans la rue sans être
importuné à droite à gauche alors il
change son apparence physique par
exemple mais il met un grand chapeau il
met des lunettes noires une fausse
moustache une fausse barbe un gros
manteau et ses draps étaient d'accord
d'accord ça va merci marianne et
françois c'est tout ce que je voulais
savoir
pourquoi casimir parle-t-il de garder
l'un que nie tout
coucou c'est moi
casimir à vous vous ne me reconnaissez
pas n'est ce pas c'est normal je suis là
incognito
c'est formidable d'être incognito
parce que personne ne vous reconnais et
vous pouvez faire ce que vous voulez
j'ai pu terminer mon livre
tranquillement
je vais le rendre la bibliothèque
seulement cette lecture m'a donné un peu
frein
julie je voudrais dit dragées au poivre
certainement monsieur
julie tu sais très bien que ce n'est pas
de poche je t'appellerai demain je suis
désolé monsieur je ne vous connais pas
et il faut que je vous fasse payer
immédiatement ça alors on m'attend une
minute à
françois est ce que tu peux me prêter un
franc
jeu je suis navré cher monsieur je ne
prêtent pas d'argent aux gens que je ne
connais pas ah bon
ça alors
julie ça va très bien mais si je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors le moral est bon françois le moral
est bon mais minime et je vous en prie
monsieur je ne vous connais pas oui le
moral est bon oui oui on fore alors
vraiment c'est pas amusant du tout
l'être incognito je préfère encore être
reconnu les déranger par tous les gens
que je connais et que j'aime bien qu'ils
me disent bonjour casimir plutôt que
passer pour un monsieur inconnu
[Rires]
vous m'avez fait peur
[Musique]